là c'est une tâche pas facile falloir en
tout cas y réfléchir on l'a fait pendant
quatre semaines on a rencontré les
personnes qui ne vous occupez des années
qui nous ont dit là on a envie de re
voter on a envie d'en faire donc on
avait la sensation d'avoir fait du
travail par rapport à cela
on a vu aujourd'hui que ça n'a pas
suffisamment ça n'a pas suffisamment
pesé et à nous de travailler cette
semaine j'ai obtenu 12,5 pour cent des
suffrages exprimés ce soir au regard du
contexte national du tout est locale et
de la dissidente incarné par le maire de
vesoul et l'adjointe degrés je pense que
c'est un petit tour tout à fait tout à
fait exemplaire